i'm going to ask you a question are any
of you watching this video from china
probably not many of you and those of
you who can watch visualpolitik from
china will be doing so because you are
using a vpn and why do i know that
nobody watches visualpolitik from china
it's very simple because youtube is
censored in china but you already know
that what you probably don't know is the
fact that youtube google and facebook
can't be seen from china and that is a
technological marvel
[Music]
censoring the internet is not as simple
as passing a couple of laws to give you
an idea it's estimated that in 2020
alone china spent over 6.6 billion
dollars on internet censorship that's
half of what it costs to stage the 2018
world cup in russia in addition there
are more than two million people working
on keeping the chinese internet clean
from freedom
[Music]
in other words the great cyber wall of
china is something like the burj khalifa
of oppression a marvel of technology
even if it is used for evil and as we
know if there is one thing china knows
how to do well is to export its
technological marvels so the question is
what if china also wanted to export its
censorship to the west well in this
video we're going to tell you all about
that
[Music]
i was born in the year 1989 don't do the
math at that time almost no country had
china as a major trading partner the
united states dominated virtually every
market 34 years later that picture is
totally different that translates into
money but also a lot of political clout
check this out
[Music]
h m nike adidas among others in china's
crosshairs for their criticism of the
situation of uighurs that's right
everyone wants to enter the huge chinese
market but that market has very strict
rules rules that go beyond industry
regulations and if clothing brands have
to worry imagine other industries like
this one
chinese sensors force disney to cut
kissing scene in mulan i'm not making
this up basically if disney wants its
movies to be seen in china it has to
pass censorship rules rules that in many
cases go way beyond cutting out a kiss
in this case we're talking about the
2020 remake of mulan in order for the
film to be seen in china disney had to
adapt to chinese tastes which included
of course adapting to the taste of the
chinese communist party the problem with
all this is that we are talking about a
film made for the international market
but another way without realizing it all
of us viewers have had to suffer
indirectly from chinese censorship
[Music]
so the question we are asking today is
how far does chinese censorship go and
should we be worried today we are going
to answer all these questions but first
let's take a look at some history
the great cyber world of china china has
shown that you can open up to the world
and keep your dictatorship you only have
to control one thing the flow of
information and if not
just look at cuba fortunately this is
increasingly difficult to achieve before
the internet there were few media
outlets so it was easy to control them
now thousands of blogs websites and
articles on social media are created
every second that explains why censoring
the internet is an impossible task even
for the worst dictatorships
for example belarus is as oppressive as
a dictatorship as china can be however
some of you probably live near this
country even belarusians themselves
share hilarious memes of their dictator
on the internet this doesn't mean that
alexander lukashenko is a reasonable
dictator it means he doesn't have the
money or the technology to control how
his nearly 9.5 million citizens use the
internet however china is another world
and to start talking about censorship in
china you have to understand how
everything behind it works we know that
china doesn't release much information
about the way they censor but
testimonies international agencies and
investigations have helped to reveal the
way this country censors
in 1994 china laid its first internet
cables at that time there were hardly
any websites in the world so there
wasn't much to censor but as the first
digital media and blogs emerged beijing
realized it had to get to work and
that's how the so-called great firewall
of china where as we call it here the
great cyber wall of china was born this
project began operating in 2003 with an
investment equivalent to 800 million
dollars this firewall has been
intensified with the arrival of xi
jinping to the government of china in
2013.
[Music]
but let's go back to the firewall its
mission was to block content and this
was done through lists of blocked ips
and censored keywords let me give you an
example imagine a news portal in holland
posts a news item that criticizes the
chinese communist party well the chinese
cyber wall would detect the keywords and
block the news story that is it would
not be able to be seen from a chinese ip
address to give you an idea today there
are companies that offer their
technological services to the chinese
communist party and what do they censor
well basically everything that
contradicts any narrative or possession
of the communist party for example
almost any article that talks about
tibet taiwan or uyghurs is likely to be
censored and that explains this news
item from 2010.
google pulls search engine out of china
the internet giant arrived in 2006 with
the condition from china to censor its
search results at first google agreed
think about it how could they miss the
opportunity of tapping into the chinese
market and its millions of users well
according to estimates google managed to
have a market share close to 30 percent
in the country these numbers are not bad
if we take into account that china
already had a search engine baidu which
at that time had 58 market share however
problems did not take long to appear
[Music]
google took a risky decision that the
communist party did not like at all it
started to warn users when some search
results were removed as you can imagine
this was publicly acknowledging
censorship and how did china react the
first response was operation aurora a
series of cyber attacks by chinese
hackers on google
at the same time china created an entire
ecosystem to give priority to local
companies in 2010 google stopped
censoring content and left china after
google facebook and many others followed
suit this was bad news for freedom in
china but great news for many chinese
companies
baidu imitates google and launches its
own browser exactly the departure of
google and the rest of the giants of
silicon valley opened the door for a lot
of chinese internet companies to make a
killing it was around this time that
companies like wechat appeared companies
like baidu were consolidated
in other words in beijing they were in
luck not only had they managed to
maintain censorship they had also
managed to create their own online
industry an industry much easier to
control than any other foreign company i
know what you're thinking now okay we
know there's censorship in china but how
can you export that censorship well
we're gonna find that out right now
[Music]
the big chinese market until 2008 china
was known for being the factory of the
world a center of cheap labor full of
factories and all kinds of imitation
goods and the world thought that it
would last forever however after the
2008 crisis china was also revealed as a
market here on visualpolitik we already
told you how lego the toy company has
managed to survive thanks in part to the
chinese market it's an old video but if
you're a veteran follower you'll surely
have seen it by the way this is a great
time to remind you that we release new
videos on this channel every week so
subscribe to this channel and hit the
little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates but let's
get back to our story the truth is that
china is not just a factory it is also a
market and is becoming more and more
lucrative take a look at this graph
[Applause]
here you can see the imf outlook for the
chinese economy technically by 2028
china could surpass the united states in
gdp this does not mean that china is
going to be richer than the united
states remember the chinese population
is several times larger than that of the
united states but the truth is that the
chinese market is attractive for any
company even more so if we take into
account that they have recovered faster
than any other nation after the
coronavirus crisis and we're not just
talking about a marketplace for selling
mobile phones we're also talking about
cultural products
sports movies and all kinds of video
content so the question is how to adapt
to the chinese market well we're going
to look at that
now
here we speak with censorship let's look
at a very famous case of current
censorship we're going to talk about
disney and the movie called mulan and no
we're not talking about the animated
version but the new version of this
movie
[Music]
and you'll see mulan but what line could
this disney film possibly cross well
mulan tells the story of a woman who
defends china from the attacks of the
evil hunts however the lead actress who
played the role of mulan in the disney
version had expressed her support for
the protesters in hong kong that means
that many groups in china called for a
boycott of the movie but not only that
the chinese government removed a kissing
scene in the film as explained by the
director of mulan herself
it was a very beautiful scene but the
chinese office said it couldn't be done
it didn't look good to chinese audiences
so we took it out nikki karo director of
mulan so the question is if disney has
removed the kiss from mulan how many
other parts of the script have had to be
adapted to meet all aspects of the
chinese narrative think about it mulan
is a film for international consumption
in other words it's meant to be seen in
all markets including europe and the
united states that means that we will
all be watching a film that not only has
chinese censorship but in many cases
could also be communist party propaganda
of course this wouldn't be a problem if
we were only talking about one film in
particular but what if disney and all
the big production companies end up
doing the same thing with all their
films
[Music]
now wait a minute because here we're not
just talking about movies we're also
talking about sports for example the nba
as you may know the nba is the american
basketball league that's to say it's
where the most important basketball
teams from all over the united states
can be found well houston rockets
president daryl mori posted a tweet
where he shared a slogan supporting the
hong kong protests this seems harmless
enough if we were in any western country
however in china it triggered a
diplomatic crisis costing billions with
a b billions of dollars suddenly china
censored every game featuring the
houston rockets took down billboards and
brought all possible pressure against
the nba as you can imagine the next time
an american athlete or executive wants
to express a political opinion that goes
against beijing's interests he or she
will think twice to give you an idea we
can find signs of chinese censorship
even at the oscars chloe jo wins an
oscar for no mad land but the news was
censored in china cnn chloe zhao is a
chinese actress who was awarded the
oscar for best director at the 2021
oscars however the news was censored by
news agencies and publications in social
media in china why is that you may ask
well because in 2003 this brave woman
said plain and simple that quote her
country of origin is full of lies end
quote and to say that being chinese is
going to cost you and this is just one
more case however china remains an
increasingly attractive market so
attractive that even those companies who
abandoned it want to return check this
out
[Music]
facebook opens a subsidiary in china the
forbidden country with this move
facebook would join companies like apple
and google which have also given in to
xi jinping's government by making
concessions in order to operate in the
country
and you may be wondering is this really
a problem are you saying that in the
future i won't be able to watch
uncensored movies or post whatever i
want on facebook well not exactly but it
is a growing problem and we may not be
aware of it because we are increasingly
seeing censorship as something
acceptable the coronavirus has made us
accept a lot of restrictions that were
not allowed before such as confinements
and curfews we'll have to be careful
because we could end the freedoms that
we are used to it's just food for
thought after this little dose of free
reflection by visualpolitik now it is
your turn what can you do to avoid
chinese censorship do you mind watching
a censored film and how can you stand up
to the asian giant you can leave your
answer in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here at
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to the channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you liked this video please
tell us and like it and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you